I was a waiter at a restaurant called  Bella pasta in High Wycombe which is a  town you've never heard of because no  one in America or even Britain has ever  heard of it because I was like 17 at the  time which was when people started  having house parties really so what I  would do when people were having cool  parties to get an invite I'd go yeah I  can get alcohol dude totally I'd steal  it from work and I wanted to try to  steal 50 boxes be in a rucksack and two  bags and was walking towards the door  I would night everyone see and my bags  are just going plain plain plain plain  plain and my boss went James a shrink  dad I'm walking to James and I heard all  of you that she got the door and she  went what's in your bag something  nothing and she looked in and there were  50 bottles of beer but because they  couldn't find anyone to work the shift  the next morning I kept my job didn't  get fired so yeah I mean I was a  terrible employee really that was my  first job